le ballon d'alsace le point le plus haut
du sud du massif vosgien à 1250 mètres
d'altitude constitue un hiver l'un des
plus beaux chants de neige de la région
nord de la franche-comté une dizaine de
remontées mécaniques permettent
d'accéder aux six pistes principales qui
depuis le sommet très arrondi descendre
sur les différents versants du metz afin
de faciliter l'accès à tous les citadins
amateurs de neige des parkings ont été
également aménagés pour leur vie qu on
ne veut dire que c'est une station
puisque on est quand même limité par les
remontées mécaniques qui sont nombreux
c'est un fait mais enfin ils sont
limités par leur longueur
on a un pied et jeu puisque c'est une
loi d'accès que nous avons des quatre
départements limitrophes
mais à côté de ça novices sont beaucoup
trop court pour faire une station est
immense aussi une infrastructure qui est
nécessaire pour faire une citation c'est
plutôt un champ de ce qui est allé sur
tous les versants oui c'était un champ
de ski qui est régionale 6 ans et qui te
vient quand même un peu de non seulement
nationale mais internationale étant
donné que les allemands fréquentes à ses
vieux maintenant notre région vous
pouvez skier à une attitude tout 150
mètres mais se limite quand même un taux
assez réduit en descente c'est à dire
que nos pistes 11 400 mètres vous pouvez
skier par exemple à une altitude de 2
150 mètres 1 900 mètres à peu près 9 100
jusqu'à 600 mais alors comme cette année
ça ira mais des années précédentes en à
skier
pratiquement sur place et entonner
quelques passes et 9 mai dans les halles
10 ont connu le même problème mais la
majorité des skieurs viennent le matin
et repartent le soir
ah oui abbas a incontestablement un
c'est le régional 1 sauf des vacances
scolaires des vacances scolaires vous
avez des allemands vous avez été suisse
vous allez des gens qui vient de
grenoble vous avez des gens qui viennent
de paris pain qui viennent énormément
dans notre région et qui reste
séjournent ici dénomma que le belfortain
ne pousse pas ici se croient possible
pendant qu'ils sont encore si l'on peut
skier au ballon d'alsace sans aucun
problème on ne peut évidemment pas y
séjourner cela pour la simple raison
qu'aucune deux localités
même modestes ne s'y trouve implanté
c'est en quelque sorte à un terrain de
sport d'accès facile et bien équipés
mais rien de plus pour le moment
d'humour pour faire une prestation est
pas il faut plusieurs choses 1
c'est à dire il faut des hôtels il faut
des centres d'accueil au les centres
d'accueil un amant il faut notamment
je ne suis pas une crèche mais quelque
chose où les chants puisse mettre leurs
gosses quand 10 arrivent le matin pour
les garder ce qui est fréquent dans
notre région que nous accueillons
maintenant pendant cette année des
allemands à outrance étant donné qu'ils
ont des facilités énorme vu leur frange
amis viennent dans notre région où
manger pas cher les coups tordus
prochaine et sur un plan plus général
pour le ballon d'alsace devienne une
vraie station vois ça c'est beaucoup
plus difficile parce que
une vraie station il faudrait des
centres d'accueil il faudrait faute et
tout un ensemble mais là ça vient après
que lorsqu'un hôtel sera implanté hors
l'hôtel est en stagnation pour eux
depuis quatre ans a lentement un coup de
pouce du département ou du gouvernement
pour que celui ci veut demain